also breaking tonight the justice
department is picking on someone its own
size
the trump administration's legal arm is
suing google
for anti-trust violations the government
says google abuses its dominance in
online search and advertising
to stifle competition and harm consumers
google calls the lawsuit deeply flawed
correspondent jillian turner has our
story tonight from washington
the suit has been over a year in the
making with attorney general bill barr
directly involved in planning according
to justice department sources
now doj and 11 states are accusing
google of violating antitrust laws
writing google no longer competes only
on the merits but instead uses its
monopoly power and
billions in monopoly profits to lock up
key pathways to search on mobile phones
browsers and next generation devices the
end result
is no one can feasibly challenge
google's dominance in search and search
advertising
barr adds this is a monumental case for
the department of justice and more
importantly
for the american consumer fox news has
learned the litigation is the result of
a broad investigation
into google's business practices
officials quickly lasered in on the
company's alleged
anti-competitive practices ninety
percent of all web searches in america
are done
through google's search engine that's
because google allows companies like
apple to include its search engine in
its products for free
in return google demands its search
engine be used
exclusively senate finance chairman
chuck grassley says there's only one
path forward
monopolies under our laws have to be
questioned and if they're
anti-competitive and violating the ant
trust laws they have to be prosecuted
doj argues google's financial power
leads to less
choices poorer quality and higher ad
prices
which in turn hurt google's users
advertisers and millions of small
businesses
but some experts caution doj suit could
ultimately
hurt consumers more than help consumers
enjoy google products they're often free
and they choose them when given a choice
they these are products that innovate
rapidly
google agrees calling the lawsuit deeply
flawed
if this case is correct it will make it
harder for consumers potentially to
access google
to access a search service that they
love and they choose to use
and tonight fox news obtains a memo from
ceo sundar pachai to employees telling
them to ignore the noise
and stay deeply focused on their mission
tonight tech insiders are telling us the
future of this lawsuit
does not hinge on the outcome of the
presidential election it is going
forward full steam ahead regardless of
who's in the oval office come january
20th now it
is true that reigning in big tech has
become a truly bipartisan issue here in
washington over the last couple of years
so it seems brett
google is finally facing a reckoning
brett julian turner live outside doj
jillian thanks also breaking